car il dit la vérité est ce que tu as
déjà craqué un peu sur un agriculteur
mais t'as jamais oser l'avouer dis
franchement c'est sympa il s'est passé
quelque chose non tu as le petit croche
dit la vérité
non un petit nom il ya eu des sympathies
des dépôts des sympathiques mais quand
je vais là-bas tu vois je vais pour les
interviewer ils me parlent de leur
solitude attendent vraiment quelqu'un
qui va tout quitter pour habiter là-bas
je peux pas mettre dans une position de
séduction ce serait super malhonnête et
autres questions
oui à l'ab les marchands merci d'être là
rien madame le marché est-ce qu'il a
déjà eu à l'agriculteur qui était fou
amoureux soit était un peu rôle ne donne
pas ne donne pas de noms qui m'aurait
mis dans leur lit ah ah ah ben ça tu
fais ce que tu veux voir un mec qui
voulait passer la nuit avec moi et
amoureux et ouais tu voulais passer la
nuit avec toi ce que diana qui tombe
draguer un peu mou parce que les gens
qui accouchent sans être amoureux on est
d'accord
bah oui ça ça n'arrivera jamais aussi
sur ce plateau van walle et bien ça oui
a déjà eu moi c'est vrai et toi tu
comment tu les bases
bah ça dépend si c'est orale ou tactiles
quoi il ya eu 2 10 à 20jours un peu
relou genre yakitri patricia pas
tripoter watts
mais voilà même gentiment quoi sentiment
oui mais moins il ya eu des mecs jouent
remparts moral voilà c'est toi qui sais
toi qui me plaît 15 avril le 19 dans les
ports frère mais le banc caennais qui me
plaît et ce quoi tu m'as pas écrit tout
ça quand il ouvre le courrier mais ça va
pas plus loin mais ouais je suis un truc
et toi jamais tu as eu un petit
maintenant et ben bravo car et nommez
moi j'habite à paris c'est alors
maintenant je vais dire aujourd'hui avec
le tgv tu peux
[Applaudissements]
les aînés
le faire tu veux tu à paris tu fait à
lille dans dix heures tu as lu à la
foule problèmes arrivent tel que baloche
nac est terminé merci non mais je te le
dis car elle va très bien ma chérie